tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
io sono fra vj e oggi siamo tornati di
nuovo su toni non ce la faccio ad
aspettare di fare il prossimo episodio
perché mia mi prende troppo il gioco in
seriamente ragazzi erano rimasti che
siamo entrati in questo secondo edificio
perché ci sono due edifici la ne bastava
uno era grosso a pieno di gente brutta
oppure il secondo edificio ben ali pure
buio sempre più bello sto gioco
fantastico sembra sia finito il
combustibile perfetto meravigliosa
impartiti da dio a esco o che niente è
finito combustibile ragazzi niente
accendino adesso è tanto lo trovo
tranquillo c'è più raccapricciante
questa di quella di prima bello un
cappio non è proprio il tipo di
giocatore che mi piace però a manca una
palla ho trovato l'oggetto bambola si
vabbè ci mancava solo l'enigma
fantastico e lo risolve in un altro
momento ragazzi perché non sono proprio
cioè fatemi più a controllare la casa
poi capisco cosa devo fare della mia
vita
mica c'è una varietà sostanza che
incredibile niente ragazzi ci tornerò
poi qua perché non mi ricordo
assolutamente cosa devo fare
a destra non si apre
e vabbè e vabbè dove sono caduto a
perché est acquista minchiona sono
caduto di nuovo
apriti e vabbè lo sapevo che non si
apriva devo riparlare gar ci provo non
sono sicuro di qualche bel culo che c'è
ora che non ne sono sicuro però ma come
quello siglato dai live e vabbè come ha
fatto a prendermi dai minchia quanto la
odio ma che cosa ci sta a fare qua che
sta nell'altra casa prima piano
liberiamoci vai vai vai vai vai e vabbè
ma quanto sei storto la porta aperto che
mai ha smesso
ok non mi segue più perfetto mi
ammazzerei veramente bella posso
propormi la dietro la maggiore o trovate
oggetto lampadina non ho capito cosa
prende non fare in una lampadina prove
quanto è grossa st kasami capo di vita
sociale
c'era 3 c'è un camino a grazie non avevo
prenotato grasse che me lo scrive
arancio combustibile minchia dove lo
trova con uno stile per l'accendino a
nick questa stanza inutile se no
accendino non fai niente perfetto ultimo
piano però devi stare calmo è una calma
proprio sta piovendo grafica il capitano
bio sto tizio a testicolo sbagliato a
chiamarti così una scatola d'oro tipo il
forziere di skyrim ci sto dentro le
spade la dovuta giù a no si incastrava
nel pavimento basta ok ho trovato in
combustibile l'accendino perfetto ho
trovato il combustibile fatevi saldare
saltare fatemi saltare la partita bello
ecco questo è un disegno migliore di
quelli che fare io di solito però boh
non ha idea di che cosa ci fa fare
quindi torniamoci poi sa che il camino
se lo accendo ma come cazzo hai fatto
era scaldato in un camino o deficiente
veloce
veloce trovatore chiede dalle pagine
ormai non mi ha visto sono sicuro che
non mi avrà visto salve in realtà non lo
sapeva lui è andato a culo che morisse
il fratello di diarrea nel cammino ma
renditi conto di quanto fai schifo motta
2 vado niente faccio il giro della casa
tanto ciotola perdere questa l'ansia e
l'ansia di mia mente quando mi seguì
salvato bari poi svanisce nel nulla non
si sa dove cazzo fini però si infila nei
camini posso entrare nel camino vi devo
uscire anche babbo natale ma di melo
prima facendo il cammino se come ha
fatto entrare nel camino non c entro
manco io ho acceso un camino adesso sì
che ho finito il gioco ma che cazzo è
servito un camino l'unica roba che mi
viene in mente che siccome il cammino è
collegato da sotto a sopra che adesso
sul foglio bianco comprare qualcosa è
infatti potevi dar fuoco al foglio
facevi prima 528 scritto con una
calligrafia che manco io alle elementari
mi ricordo neanche quanti anni noi
quando sono nato io però devo ricordarmi
i numeri che ci stanno sul nulla ci
manca solo web
prendo al cinghiale facendo cioè ecco
perfetto c'è una candela vuoi accendersi
takeshi ma che cazzo fai questo cui si
scemo ma a un cazzo deficiente ma cosa
fai qua o sei tu testicolo non
spaventarmi in questo maturità di un
ceffone chemical tv giro manco la statua
che c'è lì di fianco non spaventarmi in
questo modo a cazzo de ficchy cosa fai
qui takeshi stai bene questo è passato
da chiudersi in un armadio a passare
nell'altra casa come ci sia arrivato lo
sa solo lui il sì ma è solo una
questione di tempo prima che venga
catturato da quel mostro se non ti
ammazzo io prima zio se solo io e solo
io non avessi suggerito di venire qui
non saremmo in questo è colpa tua ma io
di fico la testa nel mio anno a questo
tizio è tutta colpa mia è bravo
eh sì vabbè lasciamo perdere non si sa
quanto può essere stupido devo spingere
la statua di sotto e mandarla da qualche
parte per forza cosa non ha senso dove
la spinta ok ma sono ricordata devo
spingerla giù dalle scale per la sua
ricordare non so perchè ma mi sono
ricordata ma me la ricordavo sta cosa ci
ha avuto un flash che ha come di sosta
che ha in mano ai ma lei nella mani per
mario non mi ha visto entrare non mi ha
visto entrare non mi ha visto e non mi
ha visto non mi devi rompere il cazzo
non mi devi lontre non mi ha visto come
ha fatto a trovarmi proprio devono
venire a rompermi le palle
dove vado solo incastrato cazzo non mi
ha seguito
che culo era morto non sapevo cosa fare
ero moltissimo
che culo perfetto cos'è ho trovato
l'oggetto pietra blu cosa faccio evo col
drago share
ho trovato l'oggetto varna la smetta di
riunirli tutti e due inserisci la pietra
pone loppsi vai vai così ho bruciato non
buttarla nel del fuoco è la brucia
perché devo pronunciarla hai trovato
l'oggetto pietra rossa progetto a ok ok
progetto tutte due le palle noi ci siamo
alzati di successo ho trovato l'oggetto
testa della bambola e che me ne volevo
andare di là fare qualcosa vate dove
sostituirla un'altra bambola
ah no
takeshi perché ti sei ucciso meno male
che ti sei ucciso tu perché se non ti
doveva uccidere io quindi perfetto e
stato bello conosce il titolo giuro mi
sono proprio divertito protesta da
bambola è lo sapevo e non serviva a
niente sto coso tavoli a risolverlo per
niente fantastici codotto ma tant'è che
minchia su un fenomeno
ho trovato un oggetto chiave della canti
ancora tante cantine ci sono visto gioco
takeshi no no no scherzavo è tranquillo
ma che cazzo successo poco mai takeshi
oddio no capitolo ama il nostro prende
le sembianze di chi uccide quindi quello
coi capelli lunghi e rata culo era
quella che è morta all'inizio ma dai
veramente ma porca [ __ ] sono sconvolto
quindi quelle takeshi lo sapevo che
anche la morto ma resti scassato i tre
quarti va beh ma se io torno qua c'è e
non c'è più quindi proprio lui
fantastico l'unica porta che è rimasta
aprirebbe e questa per forza deve essere
questa è stata la chiave della cantina
perfetto chiesto rumore bruttissimo lega
c'è la corrente in sto a posto per
cortesia si sta roba
si lavano quante porti incastrate devo
andare a pagare una candela per
corteggiarlo non vedo niente
cos'è e va bene attraverso lo [ __ ]
geni e ho trovato la genera il
generatore a caso dietro un pino come un
falco ha trovato generato a caso sono
entrato va bene così ho trovato
l'oggetto libro illustrato mi serviva
proprio un libro da colorare in questo
preciso momento non ci sono più i colori
sono spariti vabbè sidro stai calmo
calmo canu e un altro oggetto chiave
rossa a ho capito niente quindi la porta
di prima era colorata quindi devo
trovare tutte le chiavi colorate per
aprirla so come tale non sia anno devo
averle tutti insieme per forza solo
questo nella stanza sono cliccato questo
la porta è chiusa ha pure libro
illustrato che mi serve bello bello
ma è comprensibile vigono cos'è sta roba
poteva ha sopreso ho trovato l'oggetto
segnalibro con i colori della porta
verde rosso bianco e blu ed al momento
della porta entro la porta lo ammetto
non ho capito cosa è va bene i codici
con i grossi ma c'è una vite di non
avevo vista la vita punta stella vai vai
vai vai sì mi chiamo devo scassinare ci
manca solo quello è diventato tipa
settimana enigmistica devo unire i
puntini no di melo si guardò adesso devo
contare i punti in questo sono capace
1237 blu tra i bianchi e 2 e verdi 17 32
17 per 2 1 2 3 7
sì non ci credo in capo e ma neanche
share lo crea
non ci posso credere
e quanti quanti sono come erano 22
non ho capito sta cosa
perfetto erano i due come ho fatto a
salvarmi non lo so ma erano in due
quindi ce n'è più di uno
nomi che sono scioccato di nuove 2
quanti shock in questo video un altro
armadio cosa dentro nikkei è lo sapevo
io attacco muro testicolo è adesso mi
spieghi anche tu come fai a essere qui a
tanzi vedi di morire che c'è bisogno di
un mostro i capelli rossi e la curo stai
bene ma grazie a dio almeno tu sì ma mi
sono storto la caviglia aspetterò qui
per un attimo ma certo aspettiamo che
cresca al piede magari sono solo 26
mostri che mi seguono ma va bene così e
ho trovato questo poco fa portalo con te
ho trovato l'oggetto a 100 ma che cazzo
ne faccio questo è scemo di scemi non
siamo su cooking mama o su masterchef
bene rendiconti guarda si trova una
bottiglia di vino e vengo per trovare
molto volentieri
e vabbè ma questo sono stato la masca a
caso c'è il tipo asmo stato così senza
motivo vabbè nella 100 da cucina immergi
la chiamerò la chiave è rossa come la
chiama la ruggine si è tolta la chiave
usata la chiave del cancello ferrato e
ci mancherebbe
fatemi chiudere i cancelli dice le
brutte esperienze due cancelli è ok c'è
un bottone sotto al dipinto premi il
bottone che sono esplode si esplori
tutto cazzi miei qui la mia vita è
cambiata in meglio
l'ho visto storto lo sapevo ho trovato
l'oggetto disco speriamo che almeno sia
di martin garriques andrello cos'è la
direzione ok ho capito grosso giallo
giallo blu giallorosso ok rosso giallo
giallo no
ok blu giallo rosso giusto
mi ricordo più dove ho trovato l'oggetto
barra metallica tutto sto bordello per
trovare una spranga di ferro fantastico
unisci il disco con la bar poi così 6
minecraft chi crafty di oggetti e vabbè
ma perché si vabbé chiave della porta
nascosta va bene me deve spunta qualcuno
dalla porta ma no che strano chiave
della porta della stanza mai dove
diavolo se infiniti ragazze una scala
dove diavolo mi porta questa cosa qui
aiuto sono fuori sembra si possa uscire
mai mai e veloce e ci fa vedere cassoli
conclude episodio di amoni lo so che mi
adorato e quando finiscono episodi così
niente ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
spero che possiate trovare pace nella
aspettare il prossimo episodio perché io
non c'e lavoro la pace di un like
lasciate prima arriva l'episodio quindi
bombardate al video di like mi piace
capace di facebook e coniglio totale
estinzione sono stati fischiati ci
invidiavano proseliti e ragazzi
[Musica]